pas de vainqueur pour le choc entre
royer plaisir les deux équipes co leader
de prénationale avant la rencontre ont
concédé le match nul 21 partout lors de
cette 9e journée
un résultat inespéré pour les plaisirs
roi qui étaient menés de dix buts en
début de match c'est très mitigé dans le
sens où on a on a fait un début de match
médiocre à dire on était à à tous deux
une semble prête à moins 10 en début de
match on n'arrivait pas à marquer leur
gardien fait une par tasse mais
magnifique défensivement on a du mal à
se mettre en route
derrière on a on a réussi à réduire le
score juste avant la mi temps on ya cru
jusqu'au bout donc il ya là un minimum
de déception sur la fin parce que moi en
plus j'ai je rappe la petite dernière
mais vu le début de match c'est mérité
pour les deux équipes c'est au
classement voyez plaisir sont toujours
premiers ex-aequo avec un point d'avancé
sur la métropolitaine des transports une
équipe située à anthony et m et 2 m
on reste à égalité avec cette équipe on
est devant au goal avérage général voilà
maintenant c'était des points à prendre
à domicile qu'on n'a pas pris il va être
falloir être capable de les prendre à
l'extérieur
cette année on a une poule qui est très
homogène encore faut pas se focaliser
sur quatre équipes à toutes les équipes
ou de béziers enfin je ne vais pas tous
les citer mais le niveau est quand même
meilleure que l'année dernière mais york
à deux encore très homogène les plaisirs
war recevront ce dimanche 11 décembre la
métropolitaine des transports un nouveau
choc il faudra cette fois ci remporté
pour passer les fêtes de noël en tête du
classement